one of the things that I found really
funny about Italy is that like you were
telling me about this but like dude like
deadlines or like like
they're not a thing it's not real so
like we were starting the ceremony
and there was dudes like the band was
still showing up oh yeah for this like
the people that were playing for like
keyboard like for the oh yeah we're
walking down the aisle oh yeah we're
like still setting up oh yeah it was
hilarious oh I was getting stressed out
just like
because that's like not not my style you
know oh yeah
I was stressing oh no but and then
everything ended up working you know
without a hitch and I was like wow this
is just the style we show up I
30 seconds before yeah exactly and I'd
be all okay and it was yeah yeah
and then they're like see you America
can you wear it too much yeah and you're
like yeah the [__] dude yeah yeah you
should have been here two hours ago it's
always sound yeah you should have been
here two hours ago Dude
stressing me out do you have any
McDonald's yeah I could go for a snack
bucket right now that's like when that
[__] German uh airport security was
roasting me there's no McDonald's over
there
man it's
yeah it's like it's one in the morning
or something for me right now yeah you
not enough yeah a little bit yo get this
dude some [__] dust off
get my boy a whip it let's see if he can
last
I would do a whip it right now nice man
no I wouldn't
I almost brought weed
to this yeah to do what because you're
gonna be [__] up so I thought it might
be funny if you were also [__] I
wouldn't make it home
I'm sorry
I'm pumped to go home man yeah I could
tell I'm bombed not that I want to do
that right now but I'm just pumped yeah
I've been thinking about it for you know
a couple days now I know how it goes man
um I want to show you this tweet this
Festival one I want to know what you
think about it okay
I agree
oh and can you read this in an English
accent because I believe that's my wife
stopped drinking two years ago after a
night out with friends she was sick all
over the kitchen cried and passed out I
put it to bed afterwards I did a poo
near the front door I told her the next
day she had done it that's why she
doesn't drink
not sorry
wow do you think he's a good husband
talk about Duke lighting dude nice
good husband yeah that's like literal
gaslighting
yeah
not literal but yeah
you know it's a good way to Gaslight
someone what
no you farted yeah
did you just fart no did that the whole
plane ride I think if that works that's
better than hours of that yeah
10 hours of farting and then standing up
and going who farted yeah
you and then you got like 10 Coke Zeros
or hours
chocolate cakes and Twirls and a bunch
of English candy and [__] that you
brought with you oh who was that
wasn't me
snack buckets yeah yeah
um
I think that's a really if I'm being
genuine it's a great way to get someone
to stop drinking yeah for sure you have
to do an intervention or anything just
humility it's like
hey hey good morning
I did this for you yeah you should come
see something
oh my God yeah
what's that that's what I'm saying like
it's kind of [__] up
but he like her life is probably better
because of it yeah
yeah but it was a really [__] up thing
to do um
but yes it is a good way of having
someone stop do anything
um
you know yeah
just diarrhea somewhere and be like you
did this you did this yeah
you don't remember unless you do that
and they wake up they're like oh [__]
yeah yo I'm a legend for this
yo Duke in the front door I almost made
it dude I was on one last night maybe
next time I actually get it in the bowl
and then he starts he starts [__]
every night like that because he thinks
people like are into it you know so wait
this was here all night and it didn't
smell yeah
okay challenge accepted
no no no no no bro how funny am I dude
dude every time I'm out of control
control man someone cuffed me
dude I'm freaking crazy dang that's such
a funny seven nights in a row
so I wanted to just be that guy you're
29 with people that are like nothing out
of kittens like you know last night I
[__] [__] in the front doorway
stop yeah I know I stopped doing that no
stop hilarious right yeah yeah no no
I'll stop for sure you're like you don't
think it's funny as [__] okay man sure
that's why everyone loves me you guys
are all [__] laying with kids and
[__]
I'm the one who's still down I get like
[__] up and do crazy [__] all the time
literally yo who do you know that's
[__] in the front doorway literally
no one because you guys are [__] lame
my children
yeah cause they're cool as [__] yeah
that's why Kids Rule dude because
there's no rules
that's why your kids think I'm cool
because I'll [__] in the doorway just
like them yeah man you tired yo tell me
tell me
I bet you didn't even do it what Panda
Express before an international flight
bet you didn't do it no I didn't do it
that's the time is there one at Heathrow
uh no I was talking about from Tom Brad
oh uh is there one at Tom Brady
oh yeah no but why the [__] every time
we get a flight from Tom Brady It's
Bradley but Tom Bradley Tom Brady like a
Tom Brady it's Tom Bradley Tom Brady
International
you just in there this [__] little
Boxers
um and they kiss you on the mouth when
you check in
then you walk in there and your wife
leaves you yeah exactly yeah
um no every time we get a flight that
says that we that we're out of there
it's the [__] terminal four thing or
whatever oh you're getting tricked every
time ah get owned man I hate that why do
they do that there
let me tell you something man that that
Panda Express there is cocaine in that
orange really
there's nothing that hits like that
orange chicken oh my God they got a line
that like zigzags for that one
because in the other one
in like the Delta terminal or whatever
it's not even the right one it's Pickup
Sticks
which is good Pickup Sticks works but
it's not quite as good as panda
oh that's the one in the uh
in the yeah that's to the right in uh
the United you got them all memorized oh
yeah man
getting my mind ready you know
should we hit the bonus I think we
should coming up in the bonus really
quote quirky random room tour 13 year
olds no
just keep going
I was gonna say we should talk about the
missing Fighters yet
oh yeah why did our boys steal it like
that
I don't think Diddy I don't really know
do you know the story
yeah I'm not really I know that there's
a fighter jet missing post Malone took
it
what do you mean
he took it why what is it
is this one of those like you know I'm
in town for tours like you don't want to
come by the base and he just cruised off
yeah on accident damn